the future of benjamin netanyahu
israel's longest-serving prime minister
and a strong u.s ally is in serious
doubt
this morning his government is about to
be toppled by a former partner who has
barely enough allies on his side for now
to take power elizabeth palmer has
covered israel for many years liz good
morning
good morning this is a real blow to
benjamin netanyahu who's now been the
prime minister of israel for a record
12 years the man who looks likely to
replace him
is the right winger naphtali bennett a
former defense minister
and successful software entrepreneur but
he's going to have to share
power with other party leaders the
powerful centrist yaya
and the man on the right here mansur
abbas from an
islamist party representing israeli
arabs now this
is historic it is the first time an arab
party will join an israeli
governing coalition when the deal was
announced last night anti-netanyahu
crowds danced in the streets
during the election in march they'd
mobilized to highlight the fact that the
prime minister was on trial for
corruption and fraud
but netanyahu has equally devoted
supporters who believe that he's kept
them safe in a hostile region
and they applauded his response to
rocket attacks on israel in may by hamas
with a major military operation that
left parts of gaza in ruins
now a word of caution here this epic
political fight
is actually not over already benjamin
netanyahu is doing his
utmost to undermine the coalition he
tweeted this morning that legislators
who are going to have to vote on it
taking power should oppose what he
called
this dangerous left-wing government so
it ain't over till it's over
tony hard to call it a left-wing
government but he's doing so liz palmer
thank you very much